350 ready to go i i got a
oh well what happened i was attacked
i was attacked by a beatle did y'all see
[Music]
it
[Music]
welcome back tacos contolo it's season
two who do we have in the bag
for this episode i'm glad you asked we
have
tiffany haddish in the bag we have her
favorite tacos
lax taco in the bag
we also got taco mel one of my favorites
in the bag and we also have your host
with the most some people say the least
jesus trejo that's your boy
in the bag you put it in there shake it
up what did we get
a new episode
the one the only the superstar tiffany
haddish thank you for being here thank
you for having me thank you for having
me i'm loving the setup back there you
got the greenhouse you got the
tetherball gone
i just took the ball off i should have
put the ball on there so y'all can see i
could have played tetherball by myself
man i used to be the tetherball
champion back in the day no i'm the
tetherball champion i would destroy you
in tetherball
oh i will gladly accept that challenge i
was six foot my whole life so i used to
do this for him right here the
yeah yeah look at my phone this was me
bye see oh i just said i don't
know if you could hear that i heard it
crack i heard your elbow
make a loud cry oh the new look it looks
beautiful
thank you would you follow this under
the sheet ready no i just wanted to see
my moles man i wanted to see
if i had any moles on my head then i
went to see how lumpy my hair was if i
got any dings and dancing
turns out from playing tetherball i do
have a scar in the back of my head
uh because i was playing tetherball with
this dude and he threw the ball so hard
like you know you grab him by the rope
and then you like do that hit me right
in
hit me right in the face and i fell back
on my head
my mama didn't want to take me to the
hospital to get the stitches because
it'll cost too much money so she just
brought a little ponytail a ponytail in
the back to hold my meat together
back there and it's the scar back there
still it's so funny how parents always
know the
the next best thing instead of going to
the hospital like i rolled my ankle
playing soccer
i'm like i need to go get this fixed and
my mom was like nah
my dad was like i know a guy that's a
chiropractor he works out of his uh
his apartment and we went and he snapped
it back in and it it worked just fine i
mean it cracks but
i i can walk on it just like your elbow
crack huh
[Laughter]
hey what do you think should we dive in
yes editor
roll the footage
[Music]
well we're at taco middle on christopher
boulevard and you're talking to
the actual taco man i had a daughter on
the way and i was working a security job
and it wasn't i wasn't making enough i
was making 600 every two weeks
so then when my baby shark came up we
had a taco lady we paid 500
to have her cater our baby shop i'm like
i'll make that every two weeks if i can
do
i can do that in a day while we're in
the hospital i want to go buy my taco
cart i mean i got to do something i got
a kid like that that's what really woke
me up i just started practicing
practicing practicing and
inviting friends over seeing what they
thought about it i have a business
mindset i was raised by entrepreneurs
that's really all i kind of knew
we got kool-aid we got tropical punch
peach mango watermelon
we have chicken steak and shrimp tacos
but we have this one burrito called the
three meat that you can mix all the
meats in one
chicken steak and shrimp that's the
special that's the world famous three
meat
since i started to get a little
attention i'm like this this is bigger
than me
you know i'm very inspired by nipsey
hustle that's kind of what i'm trying to
do
and what i got going you know i got the
taco meal i got the beauty supply
opening
got the court cafe i got taco meal
lakewood and more to go
i'm i'm not content at all i'm more than
the sky is the limit the universe
is the limit and it the universe has no
limit
so i ordered from one of my favorite
spots
taco mail look at this i don't know if
you can see this spread
uh huh this is chicken
shrimp and steak these guys blew up
everyone from
nipsey god rest to seoul to a yg
i mean they just co-signed this amazing
spot
look at this burrito yeah it's like
it's like half of a parking stopper tell
me what you got
from lax taco i got uh four carne inside
of tacos
with the no onions and cilantro
and they put the sauce on there i've
been going to lax tacos since
the 1900s okay they started out a little
house
and now they turned it into a full
situation with a drive-through and
everything
uh yeah i started going there in 1998
i was working for an airline and one of
my co-workers was like you got to try
these tacos and they're only 50 cents i
was like 50 cent
what you got remember this was the 1900s
these to me are the best tacos every
time i eat them i feel like
success and prosperity is coming my way
okay well i got to pray before i eat i
don't know about you
yes my food lead us in prayer heavenly
father thank you for this day of life
and thank you for this delicious meal
that we about to receive
bless this show bless the hands that
made these foods for
us and made made man lift us up into
success and prosperity
and everyone who touched the food may
they be healthy
and successful as well all these things
we ask in your son's name
amen amen and and thank you tiffany
hatties for her time
and for always being sweet amen there
you go thank you
[Music]
oh this is so good it's like it's like
it's all the spices and the seasonings
and everything is making love in my
mouth
whoa whoa and i always dance a little
bit because
if you don't see me moving around when
i'm eating the food
ain't slapping right yeah because it's
probably nasty so would you consider
yourself a
a taco connoisseur i would think so i
love tacos like and i love cardamom
salad
what are the signs of a spot that you're
like man this place is gonna go hard
if i see a kid playing a kickball or
something like playing soccer with with
church shoes on
i know that's gonna be good church shoes
and it's all late like man don't you got
school tomorrow and then you find out
they're not a kid at all
like why is that kid smoking a cigarette
oh no that's the owner of the truck oh
okay
so when you're out and about and you're
eating do you have any like
pet peeves if the waiter has dirty hands
dirty nails
delivered the cuff like this the dirty
nails and they got their finger all in
the cup like here you go this is your
surprise like that man
that's not okay and my grandma taught me
if somebody's nails is chewed down that
means they sexually frustrated and they
probably masturbate a lot
so they hold it they got [ __ ]
[ __ ] on your food
i was talking your social media a little
bit before
before this interview as a good host
does and i found some posts that i want
to run by you this first one i'm going
to send you this
boom
okay
nothing's come through yet okay what you
want a metro pcs
[Laughter]
i'm texting you by uh a potato
apparently this is a
old old phone i signed up for my phone
plan
on a tent on the sidewalk
yeah when you see this picture like
who do you see i see me hungry hungry
broke that belt
that belt is well out my pants was too
big
because i was so skinny i see somebody
that's like
willing to i just see trying to work
work her ass off it makes me want to cry
something when i look at it
i was homeless at the time like it's
such a beautiful picture because you're
on stage and you're shining and it's
like
people have very little idea as to what
was going on in your life at that time
you were just out there hustling chasing
the dream
yeah i was working my ass off living in
my geo metro
and like just you know trying to
trying to create an opportunity for
myself yeah
as as a female in comedy it's like very
difficult because it's either
you got like there's like i think
there's like three different kind of
comics you got the comics that are like
supportive
and like look out right which is like
a struggle there then you got the comics
that are like
yeah i'll let you open up for me but you
got to open your legs and then you got
the ones that are like intimidated by
you like
yeah you got too much energy i don't
want you opening up for me or you're not
funny they tell you you're not funny but
it's like
i just got a standing ovation how can
you say i'm not funny
right it's like they're intimidated by
you and and you started comedy at such a
young age
and and that's got to be hard i mean you
started at the lab factory the comedy
camp
and i i read that's where you met
richard pryor he gave you a great piece
of advice do you remember what that was
well he stopped me in the middle of my
set and he was like look he was like
what are you doing i was like
i'm telling a joke he goes no you're not
i say yes i am he goes no you're not
saying yes i
am because no you're not i said well
what do you think i'm doing and he said
you getting on my goddamn nerves that's
what you're doing
look people don't kind of comedy shows
because they want to hear about politics
or religion or about
your problems or about celebrity stuff
they come to comedy shows
to have fun right so when you're on
stage
have fun if you're having fun they're
having fun
it took me a minute to really understand
it but it's something that i've applied
to my entire
existence that i applied to my life you
know what a beautiful piece of advice to
get
from from from the greatest of all time
i want to talk about
the white dress right there's something
very cool
and like so like down to earth
about you that that you didn't want to
play the hollywood games of like buying
an expensive dress and wearing it once
yeah yeah so this dress um it was for
the premiere
that my i got a stylist because they
told me i needed a stylist
and i got the dress for the premiere of
girls trip
and it's and i didn't know at the time
but i found out like
once i put it on that it was a 4 000
dress and i was like what the [ __ ]
like this was more than my mortgage like
i'm
not like and it was funny because the
stylist was like yeah we gotta
you can uh you know you can donate it or
sell it or whatever and i was like nah
uh this is four thousand dollars i spent
i'm wearing this dress
all the time and that's exactly what i
did
i'm actually gonna wear it later on
today you know i haven't worn it in a
year
i haven't actually worn it in a year
because my ass got fat but now i lost 20
pounds and i can fit it again
girl and it it's so funny i pulled it
out the little at this box i keep it in
and it's all these makeup makeup stains
on it because i never washed it
because you can't wash it right so last
night i was trying to wash it and i
think i [ __ ] the dress up but whatever
that [ __ ] yeah no still wear it rock it
it's such a beautiful i hand washed it
like this look you're you're someone i
look up to when i was a door guy at the
comedy store you would come in
and i would see you go up in the main
room and you would rock it and
you're an inspiration i think i i speak
for for many comics
i think i want to say to you though i'm
really proud of you
i'm super proud of you because i saw you
performing i was like this dude
has something you got it and remember
and i was like you want to come and do
my room i would love for you to do my
room
and uh and you came that first one was
shaky but the next time you came through
you
you killed it and like and i've been
seeing you kill it ever since and i'm
really proud of you man
thank you that means no you're crying
like you fogged up my glasses thank you
that's uh that
that's very sweet and and yeah i have
nothing but the utmost respect for you
thank you for saying that and thank you
so much from the bottom of my heart
thank you so much sending you a big
socially distant hug tacos contolo
season 2
tiffany haddish taco mel lax tacos
thank you we'll see you next one thank
you see you next time
peace
dear friends today was a great day
i got to eat tacos with shiretti herself
the one
the only the very funny tiffany haddish
i ordered tacos from none other than
crenshaw boulevard's finest
taco mel these tacos slap different
the real mvp was a burrito it doesn't
have one
or two but three meats
walk with me it's beef it's chicken
and get this shrimp do yourself a favor
and go down there asap order one of each
and bring me back a burrito
your friend jesus trejo
[Music]
well chop chop cause i gotta interview
dr fauci after this